lo que se espera es que después de esta
cumbre de glasgow que está llegando a su
punto final es que se mantenga vivo el
acuerdo de parís y así controlada la
temperatura del planeta en 1.5 grados
los expertos que han analizado el
borrador de este acuerdo han dicho que
hasta lo que se conoce hasta este punto
no cumpliría con ese objetivo también
para garantizar que podamos salvar el
planeta rápidamente pero se destaca en
varias cosas se incluye por un lado
dejar de utilizar el carbón para
producir energía dejar de subsidiar los
combustibles fósiles y ya hemos
escuchado como lo mencionaba para los
carros también es bien importante
resaltar que todas estas decisiones se
cumplen siempre y cuando se den los
recursos necesarios para hacerlo y se ha
advertido también en este borrador la
complejidad para obtener estos dineros
para ayudar a los países en desarrollo a
hacer esa transición así que hasta el
momento el acuerdo del glasgow no
cumpliría con esos objetivos tan altos
que se han planteado